clic clic waouh tu fais hyper bien le
clic merci à toi tu as lu roman ça va je
crois que j'ai une maladie de peau à mr
genre quoi j'ai une tête bizarre sur
live depuis la soirée en falloir
ah ouais quand je vois ce que c'est fait
apparues après le repas non comment tu
sais c'est grave non c'est veillette
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
wonder woman batman black widow deadpool
sourire superman hé hé ouais vous êtes
un super héros ou une super héroïne
si je vous le dis vous croyez quoi que
je fais ça pour gratter du life au
hockey ne me croyez pas qu'on va faire
c'est qu'on va voir les choses de façon
factuelle
alors qui dit super héros dit super
pouvoirs ok j'avoue vous avez peut-être
pas vraiment de supers pouvoirs
enfin à part celui de transformer des
aliments en petit pure et marron qui
sont pas bons j'avoue pour combattre le
crime s'est pas loupé encore curieux
après je sais pas vous avez peut-être
super pouvoirs en fait réfléchissez deux
secondes
moi par exemple je suis capable de me
transformer en n'importe quel organe
mais bon ok on va dire que vous n'avez
pas vraiment de supers pouvoirs par
contre vous avez tout et tout
une combi ultra moulante de super
héroïne ou de super héros
[Musique]
ah je marque un point là non si vous
avez une combi ultra perfectionnés si
vous l'avez même sur vous en ce moment
là vous voyez pas
[Musique]
alors vous allez me demander ok mais
elle fait quoi
ma combi moulante de super héros ok mais
a fait quoi alors déjà fait deux mètres
carrés et elle pèse entre 3 et 5 kg
c'est pas rien ça ça fait 7 % de votre
poids votre coeur par exemple il pèse
300 grammes devrait à et le cerveau
c'est 1,5 kg en moyenne et au sahara
jaming et encore ça des pompiers qui est
allé derniers temps mais donc votre taux
c'est l'organe le plus lourd de votre
corps ça se sait pas des vrais
caractéristiques techniques super
héroïque un bon alors en vrai et fait
quoi et bien déjà effet bouclier et
protège vos tissus et vos organes ceux
qui sont à l'intérieur de vous de tout
un tas d'agression comme les chocs les
frottements les petits objets pointus
qui voudraient essayer de les attendre
les substances dangereuses les
substances nocives les substances
agressive et évidemment les microbes et
parce que votre super combi elle est
recouverte de tout un tas de petites
bactéries sympa qui empêche celle qui
sont pas sympas de rentrer ensuite elle
est équipée d'un système de surveillance
ultra perfectionnés en gros c'est un
immense réseau de capteurs qui recouvre
chaque millimètre carré de votre peau
qui sont reliés à votre système nerveux
et qui sont capables de détecter le
chaud le froid par exemple mais aussi la
douleur et la douleur c'est le signal
d'alarmé de votre qu'on dit et vous
prévient qu'il ya un danger et qu'il ya
un souci est qu'il faut faire quelque
chose mais c'est pas tout elle a aussi
un centre de contrôle hyper efficace et
qui contrôle quoi
l'humidité et surtout la chaleur votre
convient elle vous aide à gérer un truc
que vous avez qui ressemble quand même
pas mal
un super pouvoir qui s'appelle la
thermorégulation c'est ce qui permet de
garder la température à l'intérieur de
votre corps à un niveau optimal pour le
bon fonctionnement de tous vos organes
c'est à dire entre 36 degrés et 37° 5 et
pour faire ça votre peau est là
plusieurs tricks d'abord la juste sous
la surface
elle est parcourue par tout un réseau de
tout petits vaisseaux sanguins hyper
réactif et oui parce que le sang c'est
chaud et ça circule un peu partout
du coup quand il fait froid ces petits
vaisseaux il se resserre pour empêcher
la chaleur de s'en aller c'est pour ça
qu'on a les tétons qui pointent et
le gie qui ressemble à niveau de cajou
et ça on a déjà parlé dans une vidéo ce
phénomène s'appelle la vasoconstriction
et al'inverse quand il fait chaud les
vaisseaux il se dilate pour laisser
partir la chaleur c'est pour ça qu'on
devient tout rouge
et ça ça s'appelle la vasodilatation et
ya aussi un liquide hyper bien foutu qui
peut recouvrir plus ou moins toute la
surface de votre combi et s'évaporer
pour la rafraîchir quand la température
augmente ça s'appelle le mécanisme de
sudation
oui c'est la transpiration si vous
préférez votre transpi c'est une sorte
de super pouvoirs qui sont pas très bon
et la transpiration elle permet aussi de
réguler l'humidité des tissus et
d'évacuer certains déchets mais votre
peau elle peut carrément fabriquer des
trucs qui vous rendent plus forts quand
elle est exposée aux uvb du soleil elle
est capable de synthétiser de la
vitamine d et la vitamine d et joue un
rôle important dans le renforcement de
vos mots et vos muscles parce qu'elles
aident à absorber le phosphore et le
calcium et à protéger aussi certains de
vos neurones au niveau du cerveau par
exemple si ça c'est pas un truc de combi
de super héros je sais pas ce que c'est
autant vous dire que sans vote qu'on dit
je te donnerai pas cher de notre peau
des tâches klein donc vous avez compris
c'est un truc qui vous sauve la vie
plusieurs fois par jour sans même que
vous vous en rendiez compte
au delà d'être votre habit de super
héros
c'est un de vos organes et vous savez
comme on appelle ça un organe qui vous
sauve lundi un organe vital semblait
alors oui bon je sais ce que vous allez
me dire vous allez me dire oui ok alors
ma peau c'est un organe vital
enfin à part des gros accident au genre
des brûlures et craint quand même pas
grand chose c'est pas trois petits
boutons qui vont me laminer convient de
supermicro alors déjà
calmez vous les traits du tueur ensuite
bon rester polis et puis surtout bah
désolé mais vous vous trompez les
maladies de peau ça vous parle alors je
sais on a tendance à se dire que c'est
au pire un truc pas très joli à regarder
mais que de toute façon c'est pas grave
sauf que non en vrai ça mérite toujours
qu'on s'en préoccupe
juste pour vérifier et puis surtout pour
éviter que ça devienne grave quand je
vous dis maladies de peau
vous pensez au plus connus genre acné
eczéma verrue surya this vitiligo dont
on a déjà parlé ici mais des maladies
peau il y en a qui peuvent avoir des
répercussions sur d'autres organes
s'ils peuvent être graves au début ça
peut être un tout petit truc mais si on
dit que c'est pas important et qu'on
s'en occupe pas ça peut dégénérer
ce serait d'autant plus dommage que
c'est le genre de truc qui se soigne
très bien si c'est plutôt je vais vous
donner juste un exemple les cancers au
début ça commence comme un tout petit
bouton et après ça devient plus embêtant
oui c'est un euphémisme mais il ya aussi
les maladies rares
alors vous allez me dire bon ben ça va
ça assez rare insulaire vous n'avez pas
regardé ma vidéo sur les maladies rares
apparemment les maladies rares de la
peau il y en a 500 donc ok
individuellement elles sont rares mais
comme il y en a pleins ça finit par
toucher tout le monde et parmi elles y
en a qui peuvent avoir des conséquences
sur d'autres organes genre les dans le
système digestif etc
et puis des trucs qu'ils apparaissent
sur la peau ça peut aussi être le signe
d'une maladie plus générale et là encore
faut pas traîner bon ça c'est pour le
côté physique mais tout ce qui touche à
votre post a aussi un impact au niveau
psychologique et même sociale par
exemple on estime que 54 % des personnes
atteintes de maladies peau souffre
d'anxiété ou de dépression et quand on
sait que les maladies de peau touche 16
millions de personnes en france
ça fait du monde dans un autre registre
selon une enquête récente 70% des
personnes atteintes de psoriasis aurait
déjà subi des moqueries dans le cadre de
leur travail et elle connaîtrait trois
fois plus de périodes de chômage longue
durée que la moyenne
et je ne vous parle même pas des
chiffres des personnes qui sont gênés
par leur maladie dans le cadre privé
mais vous avez l'idée au passage j'en
profite pour en placer une petite
contrairement à ce qu'on croit en
général nîmes ans majorité des malades
du pot c'est pas du tout contagieux et
ça a rien à voir avec un problème
d'hygiène non plus faut arrêter donc si
on veut résumer votre combien c'est pas
juste un truc superficiel c'est pas
juste esthétique c'est un truc qui peut
vous sauver la vie ou vous la gâcher si
vous en prenez pas soin ça veut dire
qu'il faut mettre de la crème solaire
l'été mais pas seulement ça veut dire
aussi qu'il faut aller chez le médecin
quand il ya un truc qui va pas il faut
sauver votre peau parce que
le mérite et vous aussi voilà dtc c'est
fini pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve
très vite pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici
là prenez soin de vous et prenez soin
des autres
prenez soin de votre peau mettez vous
bien et surtout portez vous bien
[Applaudissements]